one really exciting thing last year
about the Karen's Cup was that we kicked
off the event with an announcement that
the st. Louis chess club was partnering
with us chess to increase the number of
girls and women in the country who play
via generous program grant and I think
that just really ties in just so much
about what we're trying to do here at
the st. Louis chess club which is to
spread the mission of chess and
particularly to girls because we're so
outnumbered yeah and both as a player
now as a coach I already seen the
effects of it so as you know I believe
six top woman players receive grants for
our training those of us who are going
to qualify to Olympia's at least were
predicted to play in the Olympiad so we
have already received two grants so
that's has been quite helpful and as a
coach there have been several grants
that have been giving to different
programs that promote chess to girls and
I do work for an Academy with we don't
have a program like that but J Stallings
is a one of the best people I know this
Lea and he has a program in Southern
California so he has girls program as
well so he's used that money and we have
done already several sessions with girls
and it has been a lot of fun yeah I saw
that Jay is wonderful and there are
programs all over the country GC
Philadelphia my town Arizona as you
mentioned California we've been bringing
chess two girls in title one schools in
the Bay Area there's also a chess moms
program so it's not just about kids so
I'm really excited that everybody's kind
of on the same page that we need to get
better numbers for girls and women not
just for the sake of females but also
for the sake of the game itself like you
know from going to Olympia it's chess is
just a lot more fun when you have a
balanced gender ratio yeah and that's
what makes the Olympiad great and such a
great festival because there's just so
many people and it feels like everyone
is part of the game and everyone is
welcome there and I like too much as
mom's program because if you look around
and you see like so many like in
scholastic events ready city kids
playing and their parents just sitting
around and they spend the whole day
there and it's not something something I
didn't appreciate as a player when I was
young but now when I see it I just think
oh my god I can't imagine spending my
whole day sitting and watching my kid do
some
that I have no idea about so I think if
at least they know more about it they
can understand better what their kids go
through at least because when someone
loses a game I think only a chess player
can relate to that so I think if they
know more about the game how they can
relate better to their kids that's
really helpful I totally agree and I
think that's true for dads as well I
just think that the worst thing the
worst of both worlds is when the parent
doesn't know anything about chess but
somehow figures out how to get a chess
engine onto their phone watch their kids
came live and see what the engine says
about it it's like not an icon you got
to get in there and try to solve the
position for yourself so you can really
see how difficult it is for your kid
otherwise you're going to see some
parent who doesn't know how to play
chess ting why don't you play Knight h5
and I yeah I mean it must be frustrating
because you know you won the healthier
kid you wanna like maybe give them
feedback maybe the kid doesn't have a
code so you try to play that part but
yeah if you don't know anything about
chess I just can't even imagine what it
must feel like and one of the other
things we do at u.s. chess which is one
of my all-time favorite things is the
girls club which means that after the
games at a national events you can go
and get lessons from top female players
and meet other girls who play that's
really powerful for me because when I
was growing up there wasn't as many
girls who played so I actually dropped
out of the game for a couple years in
junior high school and that is a really
big attrition age like 12 13 we see a
bunch of girls drop out and then also
sometimes around the college years so I
feel like making sure that even if
you're the only girl that plays chess in
your school maybe you can find another
girl that plays in your state and make
friends you know that can help us you
know keep girls in the game because it's
not just about getting them into it but
also letting them stay in our game for
their whole lives that's what we want
yeah I think that's actually challenging
because there is a dangerous age and
especially high school because even I
think for our top female players some of
them are going that kind of Jennifer you
got into Harvard and it's kind of hard
to compete with getting into Harvard you
know choosing between playing chess and
that so I think making sure that they
stay in the game that there is a reason
for them to stay in the game that chess
is seen as something they can do for the
rest of their lives something that
career I think that's very important I
think the best way is for girls to see
role mothers who make a living in chess
so it's something easier makes it easier
for parents to think oh my daughter can
make a career out of this why not just
chess why like oh the conventional route
of getting a four-year degree why not do
this or that chess can help you get a
great job I mean one of my good friends
Alissa Malkina talked about that and our
recent interview we did for my podcast
ladies night where she talked about how
it really makes you stand out when you
have a job interview or in Jennifer
use-case the Harvard admissions board
right she wrote her essays about chess
and how she played in the US Women's
Championship and got last and then the
very next year but a few years later she
was up at the top of the cross table so
I think there's so many benefits and
speaking of chess in careers I've
noticed that there's a trend where even
if you're not the very strongest player
a lot of people are making careers from
content creation from their YouTube
channels or their twitch channels like
Alexandra botas who is another example
of somebody who's making a living from
chess but not just from winning chess
championships and I think that can be a
great model for young girls as well and
we're actually having her sponsoring
some matches with her via u.s. chess
women as well one thing that really
stood out about the Karen's Cup was that
at the beginning of the event we also
had this groundbreaking historic chess
workshop where the BSA Boy Scouts of
America gave out badges to females for
the first time in their history and so
dr. Jeanne Singh feels very involved
with scouting so she made sure that we
were the very first people to give out
these badges to girls and it was so cool
yeah I mean the way the way they're the
reason one of the reasons that I say I
think it's important to have the top
females to stay in the game because
growing up for me chess like you go in
Armenia you you learn chess to become a
chess player basically so this is
something you know that's kind of stayed
with me for a long time but I think the
chess world is big and there's so many
things you can do as you mentioned
content creation I think there are so
many different markets to cater to
like Alexandra Potter's obviously like
she does things for entertainment like
from what I've seen from her streams and
obviously there's a market that likes to
see that like not everyone plays chess
because you know they want to become a
grandmaster or anything and I was
actually thinking about this because I
just saw some post someone said like
people are so mean to me because you
know like I do not good at chess and
they call me all kinds of names and like
online like online pooling and then I
was just thinking what a ridiculous
thing to like bully someone because
they're not good at a hobby like for so
many people chess is just something to
pass the time right you're in a train
you want to play on your phone not like
it's not just to become a chess player
and I think there's just such a market
that so many girls can enter that again
like the they don't have to take the
commercial rods like this is something
they can use to make a living
absolutely and where did you see that
this was a while ago like it was of
course a woman as she said like people
are so mean to me like I lost the game
they're like call me all kinds of names
and it's just like just that like you
know it's just a hobby for people like
not everyone is super and master here
what a ridiculous thing to do to someone
because they're not good at it well now
that online platforms like twitching
YouTube are becoming so much more
professional I've noticed that some of
these moderation platforms have gotten a
lot better so I really encourage girls
and women to you know if you had a bad
experience before maybe it's gonna be a
little bit better now because we you
know we had to cut out that that stuff
right I mean you just can't have people
hating on women and girls who play chess
you know to get out there their anger
and I think I've seen an improvement in
this lately yeah but I think it's
discouraging you know if every time you
go online and like the comments you read
up like you try like this has happened
to me too you know like I've made a
video and I just thought they did a good
job and then I read the comments and
like someone's like oh Boise is annoying
or like her what like voice is cracking
which I mean in my voice cracks a lot
and then they like you get discouraged
because you put an effort into it and
then it just feels like these kind of
things almost expected like people are
less like well you're putting something
online what do you expect and doesn't
get called out enough well that's
definitely not gonna happen for this
video or for any videos on the garin's
tab of it seriously I kind of see a very
bright future for girls
women in chess especially if we have
more events like the Karen's Cup and
more partnerships like what we're doing
with us chess women in the st. Louis
chess club because ultimately the best
way I think to combat that negativity is
with positivity and with friendships you
know if you have people to vent to and
people to be friends we're doing now
exactly and so uh my prediction is that
we're gonna continue to see those
numbers rise and it's a wonderful to you
know be part of it right here in st.
Louis yeah I mean the trend is
definitely it's looking upward so I
think we have been making changes and I
think things are going to keep improving
for the girls